whoo yeah everybody's gonna welcome to
Monday melee how's it going hey how's it
going uh uh today we are very excited
we've got Matthew Broussard from MTV
twos not exactly news which premieres
next Wednesday the 17th at 11:30 and
we're gonna be playing a little splatoon
today welcome of course Beth is in the
chat room
Jason O'Malley is on the ones and twos a
perfect exactly and I downloaded this
game about five minutes ago and just
learn so it's gonna be first few minutes
this might be a little painful but I
think it'll be good
and not that you're saying no what you
were just saying you're really excited
about this game ukulele it's called
ukulele yeah ukulele so if you've ever
played banjo kazooie it's which was made
by rare they're making a sequel game
like a spiritual seagull so instead of a
bear and a bird it's uh it's a chameleon
with a bat on its head and it just looks
super cool like I just love I love all
those like n64 era cartoony games like I
don't know why those ever went to us I
don't think I did I think they remained
cool this is cool this is I'm not like I
don't get us into like Call of Duty or
like super hyper realistic you know I
look super like my guess I'm not macho
enough I just like cartoons and like you
do we grab your you are macho that's why
your your your son your manliness your
securing your manliness
I'm not afraid that I still have Pokemon
yeah yeah you don't need to put out a
power suit in like a graphic that stuff
so all right so here's the here's the
deal with this with me you beautiful is
we're gonna be looking at at matte
screen so this is you guys are looking
at math screen hi I'm gonna be playing
on this little screen right here so just
so you guys are all aware this is this
is my screen see when I do this
yes exactly or I'm supposed to guess I
chose my guy do do we you a lot now here
we go
I do I like we you that's really fun
it's this my first time playing oh man
oh it's amazing all right so this game
is all about shooting paint and turning
into a squid okay that's fantastic
so pick your you're on the right there
so yeah pick your pick your guy hello
nerd cube fan 132 Florida and Cuba are
two places at once that's very
impressive so instead I have Conan hair
you do you yeah sure
I'll tell you I think your hair's better
the Conan's I'm gonna say are you
kidding me
don't want to get fun I like you whoever
said that I think I'm gonna go
parasol jet jet squelchy I'm going jet
sculpture just cuz I like the name I'm
gonna go a little more this one looks a
little more DIY yeah it's just like a
they couldn't say Windex but it's a wind
thanks model attached to like a cop gun
yeah boy like you do all right let's
just you know let's just start rich and
overpass underpass everything yeah yeah
all right little I know about this game
that sells which is read the others I
have no idea what all right so here's
how you play so basically right trigger
choose paint birthdate and you're trying
to knock are you trying to destroy a
bunch of balloons so you spray paint you
spray ink all over the place okay and
when you spray ink on the ground if you
press the left trigger you can turn into
a squid and swim through it okay if you
get on my ink you like slow down and if
I get on your Hank I slow down - got it
so shooting ink kills you is there a
limited amount of ink uh you refill it
by turning into a squid in your hand oh
that makes sense
look it's you making a mess over that's
oh here we go
okay I wonder if I can also shoot you
man I have such low ink better replenish
yeah you know how you can replenish
right yeah sweat it was older that's man
of killing you I don't know where where
the balloons they're up in the air oh
okay can I also shoot you or does that
not see any blue where's Lindsey speak
oh I think they're like if you look I
just saw a couple up in the air there
that's like it this is also a little bit
crazy because I have to move this
gamepad but here we go
we the Wii U is greatest asset it's my
biggest weakness which is motion that's
why I play video games so now I have 200
oh good question
okay every time you both this is there a
jump button
oh yeah jump is I think there we go yeah
I'm not gonna tell you all the controls
that's okay so these ears oh it's like a
squid head oh yeah the old squid hat
wait were you finding these other
balloons over where you can I shoot you
whoa here's something you really want to
shoot me oh whoa yeah I guess I got some
kind of crazy power and it like if
there's a gate you can shoot inking and
like turn into a squid and go under the
gate they just popped up right in front
of me was that you you see me no more of
it'll best games for wii u well you
gotta get smash Super Smash Brothers it
crazy if you don't this is the first
time of my life just been like I wish I
had not listened my mom and play my
video I know don't worry it's gonna get
even more intense this is just the
urgent man I they're like bosses and
stuff oh yeah we can play yes oh you can
just so many bats what happened there we
go there we go
you have just made a mess of this play
I'm good at squirting my ink places make
sense the court said see here dude I
just found a whole bunch of balloons
here this gun I gotta say is not the
greatest what did I get the sculpture
mines I'm happy with mine not feeling
this squelching my my big spot right now
is like I'm just looking around and
shooting I know I feel like crazy cuz I
gotta keep moving this thing around I
feel like you have to stand I know and
if you they should make this a dance
game it'd be hilarious
squid squid revolution yes squid squid
revolution
you know shoelaces no you got me again
over here it's a disrupter how are you I
have no idea try you know what I think
maybe the bumpers do stuff this is great
you gotta get him killed it's beaten up
I have blue but I don't know if that's
helping me is it cuz it's all about the
balloons right I'm sure it feels good
whoa wait say that again I'm feeling I
have to refill a lot ah too much green
ink no I'm gonna kill you oh did you
shoot him
oh I got stuck in your ink oh it really
oh if you if you walk you long and it
kills you
oh is that true yeah like you see like
the blue closing it around you or your
laser sight you hold down the button oh
my god is that work for you - I don't
know I don't know I'm scared of you now
I'm going I'm going
you can see I'm building up going mobile
I know what that thing is I just put a
big wall up there
whoa that alright that was very
educational I got two balloons I
selected a few if walking around
aimlessly and not being able to look the
direction I'm going is how they scored
it I would have totally won that round I
think I want to change weapons is that
okay with you that the sculpture thing
I'm not know what was wrong with it it
was - it was - I kept having refill all
the time I need some with a bigger they
needed units higher Windex bottle of
that baby
exactly mark McCarty gets stick in the
office yes I get stuck in the ink often
by that I mean I get stuck writing
things ok get your mind out of the
gutter some ludes Mattoon art whoa oh oh
oh wow so someone actually goes through
and like I made sick I love it that's so
crazy for like the amount of work people
will put into the most frivolous but
beautiful things that's right then we
tell us a little bit about not exactly
news not exactly news um te to ship MTB
toots coming out it's got I am one of
the hosts along with Damian lemon from
guy code along with David Ebert from
Geico along with Julia Callie beautiful
Julia Kelly from guy code as well and we
we do it's like a fake it's really
stupid but it's really fun
it's funny we do OPI it's do stew for
you know it's happy and we do it's like
we look at like stupid internet clips
but we treat it like like it's break
news we can betrayed it - seriously
really fun that's awesome
and how it is it it has to be further
topical then right did you guys base
it's more just like just any stupid
videos we can find oh that's awesome so
it's all about like the latest you know
trends that don't actually exist that's
awesome and are you now do you think you
so news up to date on all like the crazy
viral videos out there I spend way too
much someone right there it's funny it's
I'm one of those people who like I get
so indignant like Mike my brother be
like dude you suits we didn't like yeah
bro I saw it seven hours oh yeah it was
on the fourth page of Reddit obviously
Bob's okay I totes I'd that's it now
what's your favorite kind of borrow
there are you a cat
video guy are you like a dude lightsaber
kid kind of guy by Hills you know this
is bad to say I kind of like oh my god
this thing is I don't know what's
happening that I got a giant bazooka man
I love cat I love music videos I love
cat videos I kind of just like see him
people be really stupid to get all right
just one I saw yesterday a headless guy
going through the not he did like a
beaded makeup to look at look okay yeah
very tragic if he was actually so
there's a headless guy doing stuff I
think that's new that's the real
newsworthy yeah it's got it is hemant
head and he's been doing stuff that's
that's really go getter that's exactly I
mean there's no boundaries and he goes
to the drive-thru and just the people's
reaction and just oh really pulls up in
the drive-thru and that it's just like
he doesn't have a head yeah and it's
like convincing where's your head at
like what is this thing that's telling
me where to go at the bottom I'm not
sure I don't exactly know what this is
over here alright you know what I am so
good what is it can't unuse what is this
whoa oh I see
does this oh this makes balloons is that
the deal when you get in the thing this
gun by the way it's a mess whatever I
have don't use it it's just like yeah
try this one okay so we should go
towards the glowing beacons
thank you guys thank you for not like oh
no trust me if people hate it and people
hate it on that's for nothing like swim
under it yeah okay every go there right
it is really easy to get round with you
on the ink express the ink Express
I think my one of my favorite categories
of Claro video is the backyard wrestling
show we did a lot a fan did a lot of I
just love like AI love the passion love
the passion people like love backyard
wrestling so they just want to do it
themselves
B I love that people think it's like
yeah but hey I'm not gonna get hurt
jumping off my house onto a table what
are you see is it bad I just kind of
like seeing stupid people like get hurt
a little bit great like I want to
consider myself like nuanced and
sophisticated in my taste but then like
someone getting hit in the balls no it's
really funny it's just so funny
listen here's the argument people always
make is the argument like oh like
whatever like these people like Darwin
Awards like are like weeding themselves
out I say the opposite those people are
making themselves stronger and tougher
take over you know what I'm saying when
the apocalypse comes that's very true
and they're also teaching us what not to
do that's exactly documenting it it's
kind of suck it's their amateur
scientists really we should be thinking
about these backyard wrestling kids and
really all people who do stupid things
for who fail videos as amateur
scientists and treat and treat them with
respect
oh here we go face to face this gun is
terrible no oh it's personal when you
have to play like this it's like crazy
are you reading her uh oh yeah
absolutely oh what your favorite
subreddit oh I wait while this gonna be
boring the Fitness subreddit because I'm
because you know I just don't get it sir
you know I'm Facebook and Instagram I
don't get enough of people's you know
talking about fitness yeah I just like
God I wish I could just see more
pictures of people after they worked out
I'm a lurker though the Fitness
subreddit because it's like you know you
work out for a while that it's like you
get bored of what you're doing what do I
do
i I do well no I don't have any fitness
ones which weird you're great shape
oh thank you so much you're a swimmer hi
some of it yeah I like it
and have you I'm not what just happened
I don't know use super jump on your to
happen to you too
yeah I don't know what happened I got
like it said you used it then I got
shoved in a bunch of green ink I think
we switched places it was like weird
thing we switch place I liked it what's
your fitness Roboto oh good question uh
well I work I try to work out like four
times a week that's a good amount it's
crazy great amount that's all I need
yeah right now I'm in a Stairmaster for
30 minutes then live for an hour and a
half
it's the rest this way to go yeah I
think so mix elliptical in it you just
killed me damn which one one one one
we're feeling good one really good I
learned to swim that round uh to go
under
cool cool Tom back to your Facebook yes
that your Facebook I do it one two three
four wants to know I do I am on Facebook
are you Monday pun day on Facebook well
uh facebook.com slash Monday Pandey is
for the site for Monday program yeah and
I'm like facebook.com slash mailbox
Bruce artists I'm like okay okay yeah
he's very it was a very stressful a few
years ago when you had to pick your URL
II couldn't change that was like
horrifying I missed the bus man I miss
Matthew Broussard I missed a morose are
like damn you know like you ever meet
those people who have like their name at
gmail.com and you're like wow like
you're a hero
yeah although my name is Erin Blair
which is like a mess like it's BL uy8 no
one else has that name or you know not
lies a lot of math you know it's like
god misspelled my name it's you know
lucky you you don't have to but you have
a real like a real first name in a
distinguished last name that's the best
comment extinguish is very generous I
would say it's like all the letters you
can't get rid of in Scrabble but just
like as a name I'll be I'll be a doll
you want to try my gun alright yeah I'll
try yours okay here's did you splat bomb
I use whatever
what I use that time öso there's some
what is sub these like nerf guns I love
oh you know what we haven't been using
this special okay you know what I think
was like you switch the weapon no I
think it's like the art it's like you
can use it also it's like the arm our
buffer okay sorry pump her up top in our
ink colors changing that one orange and
I know it's hard to keep track here we
go let's go let's characterize our cool
fragrant I know so much cooler than me
that's the thing is whenever I play
these games I'm like man I make people
so much cooler ooh I don't know if
Conan's gonna make v3 I'm I'm going to
e3 a couple of us are going to check
stuff out but I think this year because
we're going to comic-con we are which
we're all very excited about this guy's
oh it's nice huh oh this is gorgeous
oh the action on this it's just yeah I'm
looking at I'm looking at this you can't
see it at all oh because it's also
motion you know what this isn't working
yeah
I hope you guys are happy I'm gonna get
murdered here yes yeah I'm looking at
this which is basically the same thing
as as matte but only on a smaller more
personal screen so when I get murdered
it hurts worse Abba no we're not going
to shoot a remote at e3 this year
because we're going to comic-con
however we urge everyone to go - where
can people find Comic Con tickets not
about guess
it's going it's going to be amazing
we're very very excited we're spending
the whole week down at comic-con we'll
be doing some live streaming from there
and we've got a lot of other really fun
things planned
[Music]
maybe I'll go maybe I'll cosplay it up
maybe I'll cosplay like oh Jesus oh man
oh no oh no I've been talking too much
swim away swim away fish swim away oh no
oh no oh I hit the water and that's bet
that's doubly bad because it's really
easy to follow I'm just rounding your
ring and now I'm polluting don't you end
up polluting the ocean with my ink that
sounds like this is like an Adele lyric
I'm drowning
now how'd you get started in comedy was
it I thought it was I was a financial
analyst I just really wanted to
accomplish this I do not - yeah I was
like that was the place for me do you
have any crazy financial analyst stories
like oh man the spreadsheet had to be
Dubai the job was I was doing comedy and
that like just was like fairly well it
was sure I was in Houston so I I ended
up like moving to LA but like keeping my
job uh remotely which was a great set of
like the second I got out here I'm
getting fired over like some nights of
great stuff this is just it rebroadcast
yeah no no trade secrets oh I don't want
to be after yeah no yeah there's nothing
to do with finances but that's crazy so
you had the sweetest gig but it turned
out none because Andy did you go through
the whole thing of getting like odd jobs
and stuff today I was super lucky I
started just doing like college shows
right away Oh awesome so I was like I
was kind of like halfway between when I
got fired anyways yeah it was sweet man
I'm pretty happy with all how it all
went down
and did you know people out here did you
cut him about your cold I knew people
out here my best friends from Houston oh
my god before me
and I heard you won Houston's funniest
oh yeah yeah man love that people hate
on us I just want to make for the record
why do people like I'd like you to go
space from their Ghostface Killah on no
hero style we have a lot of good rappers
project who do we have with
Chamillionaire it's good yeah can I just
feel like I'm waiting for this to come
up organically oh I guess it won't know
they're in terms of nerd cred yeah I
don't play many video games uh-huh but I
make polymer clay sculptures of like
mostly Pokemon when I do all sorts of
video game characters so if you go in my
room there's no video game consoles but
they're like a hundred oh my god
characters from video game how'd she get
started making those start when I was
like four man I just like cat my mom was
just like I wanted to make toys and I
was just like yeah so I've made more
Yoshi's than anything else I've made
like a bunch of Pokemon I feel like yet
this is this is just kind of a clue into
like you're like playing it off like a
make your own toys but like it's really
tragic and sad like I just picture like
it like one single like lights down you
look like a sad story
oh I can swim so much now you know you
swimmer I'm just gonna hit some balloons
no no I'm not sure neck-and-neck this
gun though is pretty oh okay so that
thing is pointing me to where all the
balloons are so wait what is what was
the first Pokemon you made and why and
why were you like first probably one of
these starters or one of the ones you're
most proud of I guess I don't know what
I've made I've made mutes I made Mewtwo
you got me beat by seven yeah I made
Mewtwo Matt Halloween Mewtwo
I made this cool one I did recently as I
made the starter Pokemon Bulbasaur
Charmander yeah and squirtle and then I
switched them so it's a fire type
Bulbasaur with like a little ball can
come in a water type Charmander and a
grass type squirtle oh my god awesome
and yeah it's really it seems cute and
charming but like if you're a girl who
just met me and you come back to my
apartment
they're just like gargoyles surround
extras looking yeah yeah chat if you
like Pokemon sound off in your favorite
Pokemon character yes
original 151 we're gonna start a civil
war in the most people are purists it's
weird like you'll meet kids II like my
favorite pokemons like sylveon is a new
type you know what you're talking about
kid your mouth back in my day we have
black-and-white graphics 151 Pokemon
okay you know I did play Mario Kart
cooks Ron flex is that one
Snorlax smell flag it's wrong is that
looking evolutionist I think people site
there's a cool one grown man talking
about poke your mom please oh my god
it's blowing up this is great mu Y mu I
think new counts even though Mew you had
to get their game shark technically
puffs these are all really cutesy ones
they're doing like really cute I like
the hard cool yeah you like like there's
like yeah like Scyther would kill you
yeah I did see online there was a cool
thing of like putting putting like
people up to how big the Pokemon be it
and it was like horrifying like oh my
god they would all murder me like I can
take a single Pokemon I've made all my
Pokemon the scale of all the ones I've
ever made they're all to scale so I had
to like I have to like study Wow
if Pikachu's that big I have to make
sure Mewtwo's that big that's awesome
oh my god only if it's a lot about
national like net like I know you're
kind of switching up for like taking
parts from different Pokemon and like
mashing them up you were dumb I did that
one's for a friend I made Umbreon mix
with Espeon oh and then I like to cross
your hundra's so I made like like one
one thing I did was I really our
interest to I mean the original Power
Rangers Zords as Pokemon so it's a green
dragon yes they're online
the pictures are online of people with
people care that people would care Beth
let's say you hit him with a link it's
monday pundit calm slash matthew
Broussard and then if you go under there
it says if you want to see my sculptures
click here yeah there and it's a gallery
of them oh my god where they're like
really bad
look it's just like you gathered it's
just you in the different costumes like
in the disillusions eeveelution so that
was actually what started me so I'd like
started doing these after college I
always made it easy I made all the
evolutions and then they only have like
ten evolutions and then there's like ten
more types of them yeah yeah so I made
the rest of made like a rock type Eevee
a ground type Eevee I made the rest and
that was like oh so much fun oh my god
you're gonna you're gonna sell
processing yes we're gonna we're gonna
play some PC games also yeah here's what
the storm just came out so maybe we'll
play that in the future
Monday May are you a big you're not a
big game Zach I know I'm not a big I'm
an old school game doctor hexa puss
Bojack I've made Charizard it fell apart
it was too big but I'll try it again
thank you so much JD fridge you say that
awesome these are uh dr. expose these
are really good thanks so much guys
I love do it oh man I got that you guys
watch Bojack horseman ever no no here's
I'm Larry's I made Bojack horseman and I
post online and it got like it got
retweeted I got to meet the craze of the
show that was like the coolest okay so
wait if I slide up here I can get up
here right yeah yeah yeah you just swim
okay so I got that yeah you gotta try
anything
yeah hold down the left trigger and then
yeah you should be able just swim right
up oh and there you are the promised
land I'm gonna try to use my secondary
get out - one shoot I don't know why I'm
like invisible maybe that defense
especially I'm taking this dude's hat I
gotta say Nintendo always awesome on the
fashion tip I guess weird though because
it's like I can't tell ah they can't
swim oh I think I'm like some of this
good I can't tell if it's like it's part
of their hat that's squid or like their
hair actually turns into a squid died
I'm cool with either for the record
all right about sinker sinker cities
Lulla fog with that bow horsemanship
brave frontier no I never played for a
bunch of friends here oh my god don't
fall in the water again please
well you're an old-school gamer so like
we talked about
I'm a really huge Nintendo fan Oh in 64
I played a little Gamecube
I just can't wait because like Nintendo
says we do it more like smartphone stuff
yeah they nuts are going to be doing
mobile games which took years from that
you know what started that what's crazy
like I said that like this is weird to
say I'm young financially as one of the
first things I bought with stock in
Nintendo because I love the company so
much and that's how Warren Buffett
doesn't want bought stock and coca-cola
things he liked right yeah yeah which
I'm gonna be on it's not the best
investments Jack I wish appearances yeah
no I love Cheetos and Taco Bell so pizza
rolls also delicious
or this invested point yeah no I it was
like it wasn't doing so well for
Nintendo was new over so overall and
then April 1st this year they released
like this this thing you can attach to
your iPhone to like turn your iPhone
into a Game Boy awesome turned out it
was a prank
ah but people were so excited about it
than 10 it was like okay fine we'll do
it and then there's stuck with soaring
say I am not doing well with this
controller killing me
oh wait oh wait I got think I got a
couple more than I would not survive out
at all I'd make a lot of people feel
better about this yeah yeah we've-- yeah
we've-- raised their killcount pretty
high are you an old-school gamer or yeah
oh yeah love I love pretty much every
kind of but the thing is like I don't
have it I just recently bought a PC so I
haven't been painting a lot of clean
PC games but yeah I really love like I'm
a fan of like it's a pants I guess it
kind of depends like I really love indie
games and I really love kind of epic
large epic games as well so I kind of
like the two ends of the spectrum not so
much the middle like I Scott you're
Skyrim's you're that kind of you know
that kind of thing and then also like
shovel knight I've been playing a lot
which is fantastic all night it's like
an old school it's like a straight-up
like old school so you're you're not
you're not partial to cartoony or non
you're just oh no no like this game is
awesome I kind of don't have a LM I'm
more about the accounts like the games
like oh my god whoa what was that you
just did alright it's happening to me
too
Oh
there man I know people are just curious
furious with just getting around
yeah because I really just so you can
actually see I know someone who's decent
no I'm also terrible I'm up for what sit
glad you can't see you and I'm not a big
Xbox one player everybody in the chat
loves the PC so I get crap every oh
really I'm I'm not a huge PC gamer
Disqus yeah
I'm not against it well no I am kind of
against it because I'm on like computers
are distracting enough yeah amazing
works of art chef you've got like six
windows open while you're playing a game
and you're like checking Instagram yeah
I can't even watch netflix without like
weeding also being on your phone yeah I
know me neither
one thing I'll do that's super annoying
is and I guess super annoying didn't no
one but myself because I feel like I
should be doing it is while I'm watching
movie Oh Wikipedia to move your show and
watch yeah oh yeah and then you go down
hold yeah then I'm looking at like
biomass processing plants and I'm like
what am i doing I spent 30 minutes
looking up like Dennis Rodman yesterday
yeah only 30 I'm like oh he was cool oh
do you want to do a swap controls you
want to play with this one let's let him
sit down just you know it's a little
sweaty I'm just gonna it's gross good
all right great
sorry body fluids exchanged so you do
like yeah you go like this to kind of
move around you can you use plus stick
so this took I'll move you left and
right but then they had to go up and
down this might be easier for me Oh
interesting I like it where's moe so
you're on here you're on here you're
playing yes I'm really not even looking
up yeah yeah that's crazy
choco other retro games is the retro
grave clues gamer with Conan is already
out we did what we did with the with
Atari which is pretty fun that's right
mister purple 100 I like playing
emulators me too
pretty pretty exciting all right oh you
choose where we want to play yeah you go
black belly skate park rice boy nice to
know I'm not the only person who
Wikipedia stinks rice rice boys oh my
God my brother Wikipedia sings while
watching a movie I know he's probably
the most annoying person ever rice boy
did you go to rice or and I think no no
maybe it's a boy who likes rice come car
how's my olive oil
oh is it true yeah when you said rice
but I'm like how did they know that
about other they're calling you rice but
I'm like I see your rice boy whoa it is
crazy now that I've been playing on that
small screen I can't even deal with this
swimming around swimming around in my
filth like gooey filth
oh yeah
I love fallout that's one of my favorite
games you ever played have you ever
heard of fallout I've heard of it sure
it's super fun yeah plus one right I
definitely Oh cor oh my god of course
you're all over that I am like weirdly
obsessed with like post-apocalyptic
stuff I can't decide what that says
about me and I either that I want the
world to end or that I appreciate it
still going but I'm like that's a weird
like all the books I'm reading now are
like post-apocalyptic it's very Walking
Dead fans oh yeah there you go
awesome also Game of Thrones which is
turning into the Walking Dead which is
getting a little crazy you watch any
Game of Thrones I don't I'm like always
well I just started man oh wow started
bad man oh good gravy like I don't want
to go fifteen seasons it's weird to like
start it just makes me get more in
control rice boy oh boy he just had
happen F rice next to him Creed you're
like oh my god one of my brothers from
rice it's like now it's had some rice
hand lotion man yeah
wait chat tell me what to do here I
don't know how do I find that what
happens when I stand in the thing can I
destroy all the balloons at once oh used
a bubbler you bastard whatever that
means
I think yeah the top right bumper does
like a weird
I could shoot like a big balloon
now maybe after this knock down some
this is so much less stressful no
they're not what is that Jim we just
walk into a wall this is horrifyingly
stressful that everybody does Hanlin
yeah Tasha hit Elizabeth who a favorite
walking dead character
I gotta go Oh No
Michonne I guess she's got a she's got a
sword so can't I mean the governor was
not my favorite is using what are just
all-time favorite Nintendo characters oh
good question
I like did you just you just I'm not
sure what that's made of rain is that
what happened yeah I don't even know it
just dumped on it didn't look like
you're hitting me just I hope this is
fun this ink is biodegradable or else
this is sending a bad message you know
now think about it like you've got some
kind of super-powerful gone there you
got to get this gun it looks like a
super super step this is the gun you
need next time and if you don't go these
guys I mean like I've heard of like you
know violence and video games being a
bad influence but this is like kids are
gonna ruin their exactly what are the
Nintendo oh oh I love drag mosey yes oh
oh he's a video game oh yeah oh yeah
it's really good I like trunks my
favorite dragon ball z carrier trucks
again cuz he has a sword I think there's
a whole thing yeah trunks is really cool
he's like silent I still like I would
like the villains Freeza Freeza or Kid
Buu kid boots would like it though
it's just so it's like he's like the
girl from the rig he's so millennia ha
ha ha yes so innocent there we go yeah
so clean this produces a prequel to the
painted world of Super Mario Sunshine
ooh interesting it would be awesome if I
didn't even think about yeah and that
was like I I beat that game I was a good
game that wasn't under it a game it was
just a little too different from the
other Mario it's like you know and they
were really released a new a new console
they put out a Mario game that's always
super nostalgic oh that was the first
one where they didn't want to go super
nostalgic you know I mean yeah yeah they
couldn't do something new and I think it
kind of back front of them a little bit
I mean this is kind of and maybe they
needed to do that for then like because
the galaxy is one of the best games yeah
yeah oh my god just revolutionized
weirdly I'm like I was obsessed with
Ocarina of Time it's still I still AM I
made the link I think I made a link
sculpture awesome yeah that was one of
hardscope to remain what what is there
anything
what kind of sculpture would have you
not made that you wanted I just go for I
just keep a list I'm working on right
now
ukulele I'm working a ukulele yeah
awesome which will be really I'm really
looking forward to it and then I really
want to make I really want to make some
very potter courage so really want to
make power line from goofy movie
sunshine a galaxy Yoshi is still my
favorite like character no she's amazing
just something so adorable about I love
Kirby - Kirby Kirby although Kirby maybe
is a large symbol but it's a cute care
yeah it's a cute carry exactly eyesight
should be now should we just try one
player you should just wanna trade off
and try to get achievements sure I'm
battling each other yeah be battling up
to you up what are you guys should we
keep battling or gofer thanks mark out
90-95 close game before Arkham Knight
who that is fun did your plane in the
batman games i've seen i've watched my
friends play and I was as a kid I always
got the consoles like two consoles late
yeah but I would go to my friend's house
I had two or three friends for him this
is true and just sit and watch them play
video oh yeah that was good I know it's
like all of ocarina of time watch all of
Goldeneye I watched all of Mario 64 yeah
oh my god so fun online battle but
alright they want to see battles I'm a
lurker of a video game lurker I love it
I love it
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with that what are she battling
should we try to go I think I'm going
online though I I don't know if we could
play two player here while we go online
should we test it out I think murdered
what do you think bats Gopi shoutout to
sculpey by the way single player which
single players dope one player would
play or go for very game I vote online
all right let's try online let's try a
lot they're gonna get murdered
I think murdered I think you know what
though murdered that's it's will be
exciting to watch excited to watch let's
get out of here online battles alright
this world by the way is amazing oh my
god how great is this so there's like a
shop there's always I want to like live
in this world I really want to sculpt
this character that's amazing yeah I
think that is like it's kind of doable
it's a little intricate but I feel like
that's not a hat I feel like they're
just head is part squid yeah yeah yeah
their head is just part squid I'm trying
to get in close
so do they get haircuts or is that like
oh it's like cutting off an artist like
Medusa yeah yeah yeah it's like Medusa
Medusa this one Erica I think this is
online battle business online battles
here with someone that wants to show
their brothers sculpey stuff Oh regular
battle here we go huh
all right let's try it well trade off
well trade off oh my god I'm nervous I'm
nervous I'm not on any time I played
here you can go for it
no place is that this interesting no I
think oh you know what I only have one
friend on here Connie quit Plaza your
chat room is so polite and civil you
guys are great you guys are the best
no no shelter and real chat room yeah
what's up rafter the blood edge 405 that
is a great name oh my god ride the blood
edge 405 voice that said there was blood
edge sitting we're good people we aren't
YouTube amen registers are kind of mean
they're funny but they're mean really
funny really funny there's such clever
Joker talk about a blood edge on there
yeah exactly I know I only have one
friend who lafon says ah one friend I
mean
one friend in there I don't I don't know
this is gonna work online we might we
can just do first player attack on Titan
never seen it or play it thanks ollie
yeah ollie J s100 keeping us in our
place exactly
if you're just joining us we're with
Matthew Broussard from the new MTV show
not exactly news here's June 17 30 p.m.
m TV - I'm super funny and follow him on
Twitter Instagram snapchat at Monday
pundit Monday Pandey great actually
let's do better show some Monday Pandey
stuff so yeah how do you explain if you
can explain a little bit what is Monday
Monday is a game it's a game still kick
their their visual puns they're like
visual plan words so they're pawn
puzzles alright so let's see if we can
get a good enough image these are future
ones so you guys are really sneak beers
and I like to show future ones but week
P here's a simple one to start with so
it's a familiar phrase so how well can
we see that we can see it pretty well
I'm gonna go up a little closer yeah
there we go cool so who is that and what
is he doing that it looks like but it's
a mouse right which mouse oh it's Tom
father Jerry Jerry I had to look it up
okay yeah Jerry Oh Jerry curl Jheri
curls like that
got it okay here's the good one to start
with
so is it flipped on there no okay no no
no let's see so that is what does that
say on the left
what does that say that says why are you
having trouble reading it well it says
Oh doing judge wait oh my god but I
can't read it because it's very small
small another word for small Little Rock
Arkansas Little Rock Arkansas awesome
that's great I like it cuz you kind of
get the first one and then you can you
can extrapolate from there so this is
what that's a thick green liquid so
what's the name for that wound I get
killed no what is that goo
another word for goo goo slime
I'm not Rangers think ninja - yes and
what's on the left on the right city
which city Emerald City who is Emerald
City not Emerald City did all of it is
called oh yes I whose eyes whose in Oz
he said Oh who's a nice solution Oz so
that's Monday Ponte comma fine with us
every Monday that's awesome
are you gonna turn that into maybe like
a card game or I want to do something
with it cuz there's I've been doing it
for like five years so there's hundreds
of them online that's awesome hundreds
thirty-two as of today good lord all
right I've given up I'm playing the the
battles because we couldn't get we
couldn't get to server there so it's
kind of self but thank you so much Tim
Cook wait did you like playing where
people can see you her people couldn't
say okay this is it this is like I guess
oppression it's like watching your mom
try to do something click there's no
click there no up there click the cancel
button
what's the cancel button where they
cancel just click it so somebody asked
and Matt I don't know if you know the
answer this but will will not exactly
news be able to be seen outside of the
US oh I don't know if you have MTV -
it's on MTV okay grant I think we're
gonna have a lot of online content so
you at least be able to watch clips of
the show lasting and some extra content
online thank you so much for asking
yeah it off so - splatoon is awesome yes
that's true yes and yeah and and it
seems like not exactly news just lends
itself to be consumed very very well
online internet if you go to the mtv2
site there's already a trailer in
language okay testing you recommended
this super soak I really like the Super
Soaker I thought that was great alright
let's play let's go black belly skate
park man let's get crazy mr. purple
mr. purple knows what sculpey is go pee
all right scope is the stuff I make it
out of it's really cool it's it's it's
cheap you can go buy it
Michaels or whatever always blood edge
from killer instinct wrath of the blood
edge Oh Mike wait you learn it stick
it's blood it's the one on the cover
yeah scary I think so yeah you I should
make that
oh sweet is your purple 100 yes this
game is super fun I would my god that
labyrinth Oh show that to the air show
that to the chat that's fantastic
someone sent us their art it's amazing
yeah I love it I love artists coming
together
waffle tarts I do not paint my skull
who's not skilled enough I do uh I use
just my wife that's awesome
oh oh no worries uh bleh I want to
challenge you to game of Halo for a
challenge accepted okay man I'm terrible
oh my God look at this roller mr.
Purple's brother you are crazy talented
dude look at this roller this is insane
oh my god this is awesome this is what I
would have if this game was real life
I would have this roller and if this is
real life I could turn to a squid that
would also how am I gonna destroy the
balloons oh oh this is a machine gun
yeah oh yeah that can't that gun is
awesome oh yeah this is the way
my controller it's got this roller thing
is super slow thing coming after you
yeah look yeah Lulla fun love these
paint rollers it's pretty great
I like a little game this is all I think
like this so people in the audience uh
people watch it ah yeah aren't that much
better than us naturally skill for sure
oh I can run with this down oh this is
great oh dude yes this you know what I
gotta say Street roll the roller hit
gets you gots to roll punk Street oh
that's what that's what the kids say
yeah
all the kids be Street rolling each
other and Davis was on the show right
Gabrus once we played FIFA 2015 which is
my grammar he he was better than me I'll
tell you that didn't I work out of the
same gym and it took us years to figure
that out is that true that's hilarious
all right get yeah yeah you know each
other from Geico and I'm coming too oh
yeah oh he's the guy code and the other
is there ah I did it I did a podcast
with big and ribs yeah yes yes he's this
like I thought he was just like a big
meat like meat head he's the nicest
sweetest guy he told a great story about
with Rita Ora like how like she
basically asked for his phone number he
like gave her that's funny because like
I've said realize now like I'm more I
I'm more careful with my um with my
email now oh sure sure yeah like you
know it's like that and we know you
didn't get Matthew Broussard a Gmail so
no I did not exactly the mystery remains
what edge though maybe maybe you are the
wrath of blood edge you got at gmail.com
who while I'm actually hand lotion man
oh man we're all tied up or get killed
in this ink over here all right I've
been spraying a little more liberally I
just have to say I hope everyone in the
chat is a priest
restraint with which Matt and I are
using our comedic chops with all this
ink being sprayed around I just want
that known I mean there's some kind of
metaphor you could either make I don't
know what it would be in a little water
I don't know what it would be just
springg ink so freely so much restraint
okay Carl yes elder scrub this game is I
mean Elder Scrolls is also fun but this
has way more paint action I don't think
they see you spray nearly as much pain
in Elder Scrolls elder roles though
trying to use my secondary weapons more
that it's our beat where they know where
you come from I don't even know where
the bullet were you just killed me I did
I don't even notice I'm just running
around blind I have a rough way to is a
killer game is this drowning and I know
that's a pretty rough very very fond
villain yeah yeah expect me to talk pink
finger or something
and now you're launching these grenades
at me I don't know where they're coming
I don't know what almost hear me I don't
even know I don't even know that I'm
launching them or maybe that's just my
paint being thrown away I guess but this
roller is hard to tell it's going on
Oh No your town thing no I just got a
chill in my own ink for a second oh my
god I'm always dead of magic paintbrush
elder scrolls but then again they did
release like a whole DLC in Skyrim where
you could just like clap like have a
family and just stir Haley you provide
anybody you just like how to farm it was
it was yeah it's just it's not oh yeah
that was like a reddit thing of like I'm
sure all that by your wife that's the
whole thing it's like they're getting so
like crazy crazy
Oh hit day yeah I hit good thing on
there they're getting so crazy like
realistic it's specific I mean I guess I
never played you were you a sims guy at
all and your place in sims yeah uh your
play like though we know that that all
sin rematch oh my god United dying to
look like that I I don't know I don't
play sims I just I know it's like a good
test to see if someone's a socio yeah
that's true you know what I never
thought about that I did there's a whole
ready there's a whole reddit thread it
might have been in a gaming thing Gaming
is also i lurk on gaming all the time
yeah that's fun but someone yes got
Street rolled that's a powerful weapon
let's just not be gonna getting balloons
or something yeah it's hard to it
doesn't shoot um but what was the worst
thing you've ever done in a video game
and everyone died say Oh funny oh my god
people were like like I would like make
Sims and like like like erase the door
and just have like terrible stuff going
across yeah basically yeah this seems
just horrible work on crimes against
inanity oh my god oh crimes against
humanity doesn't become like some kind
of a book I don't know what is oh dude
yeah
oh that was so hard I don't know how you
didn't kill me there that's a waffle
tarts somehow we all know about removing
pool ladders I think we found out the
sociopathic now change what's the worst
what's the worst thing you've ever done
in a game back at the oddest besides
remove pool ladders use heartless but
when I do it's only to murder I love it
I've done embarrassing things as I
enjoyed orchid and Killer Instinct way
too much is it good wait what was that
what do you mean oh she's sexy yes
you're like take off her top ever play
primal rage no what was that I was like
a it was a contemporary to like killer
instinct but it was with like dinosaurs
and monkeys and one of them like there
was this gorilla you play des and like
your finishing move could be like to
urinate on your dead oh my god Ted yeah
that's crazy we had it was really fun we
had the creator of Mortal Kombat Edie
Boone come in and talk all about like
when he was creating the characters and
stuff and I didn't know this but he also
does the voice for scoring feeling good
over here
that's like him that's the creator and
he's like the coolest most mild-mannered
guy and then he just this voice from
Hell comes out of his mouth that's
awesome his boss you can find that in
our past broadcast link the cameras be a
hero oh my god he was so cool legendary
and like also it was really cool like we
were talking like the dawn part of you
know oh my god we were talking about how
you know like rice boy friends it's like
named his his handle off just as he had
rice next to one of the characters in
Mortal Kombat is he revealed his named
after just an error I had eMac Ian like
an E macro error was just something so
he just named the character after this
error that kept coming up and he was
trying to
that's so funny that's pretty great what
other character I think it's just gonna
be back and it was a macro error was
like what it's like crazy it was like
man it's really cold outside it must be
like sub-zero oh man I wish my dog would
get it get over here
my dog scorpion would come in from
outside get over here
Adamsville Ed Boon needs to fix mxk on
PC you know where Mario's name comes
from No so you know you know hi Nintendo
started right no no no tell me what I
don't know are you playing down or you
know I honestly don't know it was a
trading card game I didn't know I know
but the mother doesn't training much
such an hat because it was easier to
animate yes yes but the Creator back in
like whatever one of the original
customs had an Italian landlord works
behind on his rent
no I'll name this character after you'd
like to try to win him over that's crazy
so it's named after al a new marco 19
net best trash talk line that's pretty
good while you Street rolling I'm gonna
street roll you to death
plugging this in oh I like it when you
just yell at someone you're gonna get
beefed that's my favorite trash talk you
guys don't like getting beef beef honey
what's a good truck give a good trash
talk line basically all the lines that
they say in a Sandlot oh yeah Sarah but
what's just even has like alliteration
yeah
fart sniffer is a good one farts
definitely good one Kino get over here
I'm raiding the fridge
oh go to antosha raiding the fridge
oh that's a good pun that's great right
that gets my stamp of approval oh yeah
oh we do have a beach sign because
people use it so much you get beefed you
get beef what's it what can i what is
the etymology when you get when you get
destroyed you get beefed okay you piece
me you know
idea where it comes from I think we just
made it up to you that's a yeah Steven
Smith it was a guy
what about like soy chorizo for like
yeah I got soy trees are so hard
Suri's yeah you made the trees that
overheat exactly I feel like I want to
try to plan online again is that crate
should we give it another shot or maybe
should we explore the world what do you
want to do let's go back to the Plaza
let's explore the world a bit its
explore to consider one person thing
yeah
suction ba suction bomb again Matthew
Broussard not exactly news coming out
next Wednesday premiering at MTV to
11:30
are you nervous nervous about the show
premiere I haven't watched it yet it's
crazy
I'm excited I'm just excited it's just
fun man it was what was one thing I mean
is this this is your first kind of fake
new show I'm guessing you've ever they
saw me in Tana but they're like you seem
like an excellent like fake news anchor
I'm like that's all I've ever wanted to
hear was it what was one thing that kind
of surprised you about when you were
shooting how long did you guys write for
um I was not a heavy part of the writing
process team was so funny and it's what
we have that sets us apart from other
like clips show some clip shows out
there is what we do is we take a lot of
like just stupid clips and then we put
them together under like some weird we
put them all together and just needed
like like one of the funniest segments
is David Ebert is our correspondent one
of the funniest human beings I've ever
met he's the weimar edik that's really
just that he he did a segment where I
he's talking to me and he's like Matthew
I'm here we're trend watch and I'm gonna
tell you what all the kids are doing
it's called ostrich egg and it's just
people just falling on their head he's
like it's the coolest new thing is like
a day I'm pretty sure they're not doing
that I just joined an ostrich in gym and
it's so funny that guy looks like he was
hurt why is it's like it's so bad like I
wondered like like people getting hurt
online is just so funny stuff
I gotta say oh here we go so just so I
didn't wait I know we're doing here do
something do you just try to cover it
with your thing I got into yeah it's
that one the way it's on it's on this
though so people can okay watch you yeah
so I don't I guess this is just recon
I'm trying to figure out how to do
battles online everyone
do you like I just like go go for it
virtual version of The Witcher I know
yeah it's super quiet I don't know then
we just see one zombie yeah right the
dead come over the wall you'll be seeing
someone squid hair like lol ostrich in
Brooklyn says oh this is offline
practice mode recon is just us
practicing our surveying the mat right
okay in terms of like ratio of cool
sounding name to lameness of the actual
task recon it versus practicing yeah
this is just practice excited you guys
battle join Frank hunt
thank you Father thank you baffle thanks
for telling us but not making fun of us
at the same time exactly but if you're
gonna make fun of us and do any engine
in a jelly way as I've done the right
area we're not online
hello Sweden yeah yeah we're getting
countries yeah what kind of countries we
got well because since we do it like
kind of mid day we get a lot of like a
lot of times we'll get people from all
over the globe yeah that's right all
over the globe we're learning about
Monday pun day that's right exactly
Monday me melee monday pond air curry
your you uh you were getting sculpey
tips from people all over the world
right now do you have any questions
about sculpting that maybe the chat can
answer
yo uh or does the chat have questions
about sculpey that may be mechanism
either way I just sculpey I only use
scope III does anyone use any other kind
come in scope scope is the medium
scobie's the type of clay this type of
clay well technically it's the brand
name it's a brand but sculpey I see eyes
exams like its scope you like what
people are calling it like that's what
you say so cops don't know yeah
I mean you guys sculpey buddies call
booth like almost the blast or at my
trench coat
I'm on hook you up isthmus copy brown
email what do you make Tasha super
sculpey there's that super scope is like
good for like one color stuff right
waffle tarts sweet scoop super sculpey
swatches I think it's like a big gray
block so it's closer to like terracotta
in terms of like you actually build a
bus and whoa that's bananas should like
see my sculpting oh you sure that would
be very slow sculptor right in fact
series that's a great idea mr. purple
wants to see the oh yeah with a link you
should we should do a livestream of you
stopping character wawel maybe will play
a Pokemon game and I also need to make
Conan okay I should sculpt and any
suggestions for what to make I like more
cartoony stuff but throw it at me oh
yeah
beige super sculpey firm is gray firm is
good oh so is it different colors based
on whatever it is whatever is like
different clothes have different
textures I think but you can do single
player campaign mode and amok says I
didn't see that though are you a kid or
a squid you know what you're a rapper
are you a rapper kid or school yeah look
at that I'm gonna say I'm telling you
man that outfits are on point in this
game where we came with the outfits in
this game Touche they must had a really
big wardrobe budget oh yeah what do we
think
I will the here is one kids here's one
gripe about this I can't find where to
go how do I just know where to go for uh
for single-player campaign or we can
play some single-player campaign where
do we think we go here do these
characters have nowhere to be yeah
they're just chillin
aren't you guys supposed I'll be in
school what the hell I think children
yeah where do we think we go talk to the
guy in the sewer great near the tower
thanks new box how do you guys feel
about me just wearing a sweat bath super
higher the top will you scold me like
one of your french models here we go no
mocks
hooking this up all right we're gonna
play campaign mode we'll trade off lies
how does that okay and I think you're
gonna play you'll use this but plan
here we go this games off I want to be
there no mocks you saved this dream this
is like an Instagram vacation photo the
laughing wise man what the hell is a
school once in 89
OMG yes you should play this this game I
have a beard where my mouth should be
cotton cuttlefish is the name yes I lost
my cool for a minute that dude looks
like I know who I'm going as for
Halloween this year what's your best
let's say you what's your best captain
cuttlefish impression ready nobody
believes me but it's the work of the
octarians
no it's good no he's a captain though he
went fine he's made it up in the ranks
they want revenge for the great turf war
hundred years ago oh we got some Scott
what about you uh yeah I just kind of
like its I just force it out like it's I
feel like if I do that voice for too
long like I feel like I'm just forcing
it out like it's taking years off my
life when I do that voice you think we
can pour but what if that's like a
boutiques mom huh it actually cost like
$400 that's all Kanye it's like yeah
yeah Couture yeah oh my god all right
skip all this skip all this we're
getting down though whoa I'm all Kim
Possible we're gonna let's dance
dancers oh those are the new beats
there's the new beats out there you got
the do it there we go
shooting to reveal the inches this da
okay well I see we have to fight we have
to shoot the ink so we can dive our way
in wow this game is awesome yeah I like
that
the laughing wise man I like how he has
his daisy dukes I'm gonna do this
project good point Dumbledore cosplay
Marco Walken
okay and if you want me to take over I'm
happy to do it as well we'll trade off
as quiet cabin cuttlefish I can't see
shooting to reveal the engine to do the
I'm about to throw up every time I do
that just like way low easy but working
just popping out left or right place
stop doing that voice no it's cool now
you have to talk like that forever I'm
just gonna shove my kidney back in ya
those new beats are sharp bus so since
then you know we're talking about beats
on point well they actually enter level
pedra duck tell us where to go if anyone
knows where to go tell us where to go
we're here to uh john dubs this might
look like a kiddy weed game but it's
deadly serious thank you this paint is
acidic I also like to make believe that
it smells delicious like a normal like
orange gum Oh see I was I don't mind
that oh the green sickle dreams that
creamsicle stop
I hear the next system of consoles is
gonna have smell of it due to cuttlefish
Island color fish one of my favorite
animals shoot it with an invisible
teapot
[Music]
oh wait is that it oh it you know it
actually try the great maybe maybe just
shoot the great going or do week we came
for that great forget it
yeah we're we supposed to go here right
in front of you right there right there
I guess so
oh that's great look at I love that
animation on the tree it would help to
have a map in this game I think go back
go back keep shooting it keeps shooting
it keep shooting
no wait someone just hates trees all the
other great there's another great you
worship great great oh the one oh this
right there I think it's this try
getting up on that and then going in yes
CL is the left trigger zoo Inc thank you
guys yes thank you chat thanks for
telling us where to go we're dumb whoa
dude catch the Zap fish what does that
mean alright so zlz all over the great
there we go Oh awesome and things like
that yeah oh yeah I think we gotta just
dodged the Oh God there we go
you got this comes blazing bah bah bah
remember if you hit Z remember you hit
the left trigger you can duck down to
probably
nice invader these play exactly like the
bonus levels in Super Mario Sunshine
I've never played those levels but now
maybe I wear the bonus levels you have
to you yeah I don't know listen around
yeah would it be more helpful if we
change this you didn't have to use Oh
using them to stick anyway this be okay
so what am I doing here what is this - I
think the motion controls and settings
of plays better alright
we're taking off motion controls and so
I didn't really swim to avoid yeah yeah
because you're not super powerful
imitates gonna get a couple times I
think you're dodging in return dr.
Valley maybe I'd rather not return dr.
Valley I put in so much hard work yeah I
mean I've like havin kind of fish tell
stories they're just a little too long
the mean City good gravy we gotta go all
the way back there make it quick
in the sensitivity thank you new box
here we go let's kill these settings
here we go it's really cool the new
games like this is if I were to sculpt
one of the characters like it hasn't
like they haven't made action figures
yet right yeah that's a that's a half
with Bojack horseman that's a good point
no I do I just you read it I'm to attack
they take a long time to attach to
either either I love them and don't
wanna get rid of them or I get really
tired of them and just give away just
like oh you like this keep it yeah it's
crazy you get and my rule is that I
don't like unruly Commission stuff but
if someone suggest something and it's a
really cool idea I will make it for them
oh cool spires we don't want to build it
oh that's awesome all right so yeah
thank you if you want something by the
way Oh guys if you have like a really
like awesome I don't wanna bet just for
face being just or nibbled away at
Pikachu just pick just nibbling at her
neck
Celebi because you get zombie Pikachu
just a little nibble zombie Pikachu be
funny that would be great you can pick
yeah you can make a whole thing as
zombies yeah yeah if you have a great
idea for scopes company think hit him a
pen on Twitter at Monday pun day all
right now we're in we're back in motion
controls are off thanks whisper here we
go
thanks it's called Conan's there I do I
do it like that would be that would make
it like kind of really fun to make this
the hair that would be great perfect
I'm gonna say out of all the art
designing in videogames I think I would
want to be part of Nintendo's team with
us oh it's beautiful it's just gorgeous
absolutely gorgeous it's just so cute
yeah it's cute without being like too
innocent
like right right exactly you should go
check out the art for like like fancy
cuz do we still some of the best art I
gotta play I'm gonna play that that's a
hard game I liked I liked a challenge
that I like the challenge John one of
the best things I do to get like big
publicity for like is so how do I beat
this guy drafter hide yourself a deal
oh yeah I think it's you just gotta get
past a nice women past him alright I
can't see me oh and then behind hidden
behind maybe hit him in that tentacle
fleshy parts he's Justin yeah nice
that's right we do
ooh I'll allow someone actually do
Pikachu with Conan's hair that's a great
that's a great idea great idea thank you
by the way also lol someone actually I
think also follows managed to grin
because it's and I have to say well
played with that name because when it
comes up it says lol somebody actually
liked your photo very clever very clever
you're mean in a clever way yeah it's
awesome
by posting art it really does well to uh
er the communities out there yeah I mean
like I posted on Bojack horse the are
Bojack horseman and that's the art
director for the show Lisa Hanawalt
saw it there Oh awesome I'll watch Pat
it up lunch Pat it up go back oh that's
all that's super cool like that's one of
the things that blows me away the most
is like people see stuff like people see
stuff you can get visit it doesn't
matter who you are it's like doesn't
matter you are my stuff got seen not
because of like like he could I could
have been anyone it would have been seen
that's right party I just posted on
reddit it doesn't matter if you posted
there before if you have a following
yeah waffle tarts yeah hash tagging is
your friend as well absolutely yeah
using hashtags in that stuff hashtag
works there so maybe you know you can
throw a bomb to with are for use are
distracting with a bomb then attacking
from behind you so are is the top one
this so maybe yeah maybe and maybe aim
it behind him so you can get a behind it
well there we go
[Music]
mr. Burke 100 no problem thank you hello
oh is that the one where it's like no
one this super private Facebook home
safe down here
hit harder throw bombs he gets
distracted oh yeah so I guess yeah I try
to shoot it behind him oops
ah Peck sir
the game is splatting splatoon we're
playing today there you go I think maybe
didn't you just gotta shoot him
the game is splatoon the guest is
Matthew Broussard he's on not exactly
news which premieres series premiere
everybody mtv2 next week on the 17th at
11:30 I also find my guy code it's like
war between ah yeah I guess so this is a
really fun single-player crazy
it's do the trick is to lay the path
what it crazy how do they think of this
man those look nice what if you like
meek I in my mind I know it's like a
cheap joke to make but there has to be
some drugs of all happy right this have
to or just other people like waiting all
night you'd be like what did you shoot
my like I was I was a person but I was
also squared now I would like shoot ink
and I could swim okay oh my god I love
it in my mind the way they came over
that I would love it if it was like the
end of usual suspects
except you know it's like did it did it
but someone's just looking at a snail
it's like tits and they drop their
coffee cup like oh yeah pika code Oh
hashtag pika Conan I love it iron lung
2k8 we shot a very special clueless
gamer on Thursday last week and it'll be
on the show either a week from today or
week from tomorrow so I'm very very
excited it was a large undertaking a
very large organ Jengo
I think it's gonna blow a lot of
people's minds it's really fun
and now I'm working on the next one past
that things things what games you guys
want to see some people have said Batman
some people have said fallout 4 and the
graphics drink was you're beautiful
right they do some way of like not
having the a Lions shown the cloud some
honest advice we just turned the motion
controls a half because it was making
people sick but when we play this game
I'll probably play with motion controls
on but for this for you guys I think
people were okay sorry guys what you
guys think I should throw a bomb behind
it and then try to jump up there and
kill it
so can you yeah can you well can you
scoot up the side by spraying the wall
and jumping up there or no yeah there's
logs that would be in saying I'm not
saying oh yeah oh I guess we can't get
up there so if you jump you can you
throw a ball up there yeah and I think
yeah head up in the back over watch five
nights at Freddy's people keep saying
five nights at Freddy's first up
you'll let me slide pensee motion
controls pyro 101 I agree much of girls
are Draper oh nice you're on top there
we go but not so much when you're
streaming motion controls might not be
good for people watching what am i doing
did you see Mad Max the movie
it was so unbelievably sane so
good-looking fact like yeah like George
Miller is what like 70 73 years yeah he
did the originals crazy the other movies
no god oh I get out of here
follow your beats your Beats headphones
are telling you where to go oh that's
why they're there I love it
oh yeah oh yeah lol you can still him
upwards though with the right stick yeah
yeah but yeah we had to turn off this
big moon rock band would be fun we
played a little rock band when we did
the Lewis gamer in the stadium Beth can
hit you with the link at the very end
which was super fun I couldn't I got to
play oh my god this is horrifying by the
way these are totally gonna give me
nightmares
good god oh oh my god that's fun yeah
this game is awesome
and they feed the fish but I'm feed the
fish limit as much time underwater as
you can because they can't get you and
then you can really sneak up on it
they look really smart but they're not
yeah I'm just gonna hey real quick I'm
just go throw a bomb off the building is
that cool with everyone all right so it
doesn't do anything great I just wonder
why they don't get along
why yeah like are we villains to them oh
is this like some like conflict
I like this is it that's a great
existential question you know it's like
the original Omega man in the book how
it was like like you thought yeah ssam
bees there's actually him who's the bag
that's right I've legend yeah yeah man a
lot of people's minds are blown people's
minds I mean philosophers philosophy Oh
Deb are you flirting with us reach the
top of the page the top of the pillars
big boy or girl is that girl either way
either way swim back and forth
refill my goo I gotta say this game is
making me wish I was kind of a squid
it's this make him around is great that
green and purple actually kind of go
together I know that's true there are my
college colors oh there we go and you
were a swimmer this game is you this is
my guys this is your game
Oh - best subreddits by the way I just
want to look at them together dogs with
the eyebrows cats with mustaches
mustache this is natural they naturally
have a must absolutely face very regal
very very most interesting man
dogs with eyebrows they just tape or
draw photos my god so it's not
photoshopped though it's like they
actually do yeah we have to just have
like goat cheese and yeah really cute
that's awesome amazing
make for the vault the vault we go birds
with armies yeah sorry I'm sorry I left
them out
Bernsen arms cats with the mustaches
dogs with eyebrows woo checkpoint you
know what I hate to say it it might just
beat this level and that might be it
do you want to finish playing you want
to finish can you want to the end
dodging around this yeah you're nimble
maybe yeah you know what squid is kind
of nice actually my spirit animal is a
penguin
what's your spirit my Patronus is an
otter Oh like even though I know her my
and he does it but like otters isn't my
favorite they're their aquatic yet
they're playful that's good yeah exactly
they're fun they're cute they're cute
little guys mine's a penguin cuz it's
kind of like I'm looking I feel kind of
like as a human I'm kind of I don't know
chanel flightless bird I don't know what
that means take from that what you will
no way rat the blood I it's Turtles with
beards is not Turtles with beer pretty
great good band name turtles and beards
what if you just got like really obscure
just yeah like like whatever like I'm an
animal we haven't I know I know your
cats with social anxiety does is is not
standing up yeah exactly
someone watch Fight Club slide yeah
that's right penguin in Fight Club oh
that's true yeah yeah alright that's it
Austin movers laughlin sneakers spirit
animals a peak a peak accountant they
really like the speak economy
cop does that fit was fun guys awesome
well thank that you guys are joining us
addicted the video games now amazing
Matthew Broussard again Wednesday the
17th not exactly news mg2 nice 11:30
follow this guy Twitter Instagram
snapchat at Monday Monday and Monday
Monday calm / Matthew Broussard and
that's it thanks for joining us man
thank you so much they must let to thank
you guys for joining us we'll see you
next week for Monday my leg
[Music]